la journée mondiale du livre et du droit
d'auteur fête ses 20 ans aujourd'hui
cette initiative de l'unesco est célébré
dans 80 pays
pourtant avec l'émergence du numérique
l'industrie du livre est en déclin
depuis quelques années des gens un peu
partout dans le monde
au canada les éditeurs produisent
environ 16000 nouveaux titres par année
mais c'est beaucoup plus que la demande
du consommateur car les revenus de
l'industrie d'édition ont diminué de 6 %
entre 2010 et 2012 et au québec les
ventes de livres neufs ont chuté de 9 et
demi pour cent depuis l'année dernière
seulement
mais demain la ministre québécoise la
culture hélène david promet une
importante annonce pour soutenir
justement l'industrie du livre alors on
suivra ça et j'accueille avec grand
plaisir l'animatrice de plus on est de
fous plus on lit dans l'église arsenault
bonsoir au soir alors est ce que
vraiment l'industrie du livre va si mal
que cela elle a besoin d'être soutenue
alors c'est une bonne chose si la
ministre intervient à compter de main
excellente nouvelle a besoin d'être
soutenue comme toutes les industries
culturelles un bien de consommation
c'est un bien de consommation qu'on peut
écarter peut être facilement parce que
les gens ont beaucoup de difficulté
financièrement à l'heure actuelle on le
sait les familles on sourit on se loge
après on achète ben malheureusement
parce que dans le fond moi je trouve et
où je crois que vous le pensez aussi que
le livre c'est essentiel à la vie aussi
mais c'est pas la chose la plus
essentielle
évidemment quand on est dans une période
de difficultés économiques cela dit les
gens empruntent beaucoup des livres
aussi une bibliothèque sont pleines les
listes d'attentes sont longues et nous
on étend donc quotidiennement partout au
pays
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que le
plaisir de la lecture continuez
continuez lui d'être très présent ouais
justement pour l'occasion vous amener
une liste des livres incontournables
canadien et livrent donc écrit ici au
canada c'était vraiment une belle
initiative
ça ressemble à des médias comme le
guardian ou le monde en comme ça donc
diffusé une liste et provoquer des
conversations parce que beast fat ça
génère des conversations les gens sont
jamais d'accord légende il manque son
arrêt du on arrête je trouvais telles
choses ou tel autre chose
donc c'est ce qu'on veut faire en fait
sucrer une conversation autour de la
littérature canadienne la littérature
québécoise qu'est ce qu'il faut lire
qu'est ce qu'ils racontent le mieux
notre histoire notre identité notre
parcours de territoire notre culture
alors si ce mot invite les chasseurs
canadienne
existe oui elle est florissante et
vivante plus que jamais nous on est là
pour témoigner on mange jamais d'inviter
ses les montants dont tous les jours
quand même donc des gens qui racontent
des histoires y en a beaucoup et il ya
des nouvelles générations qui pose
perpétuellement les jeunes filles 18 ans
20 ans c'est formidable donc on demande
aux gens avec les animateurs de radio
canada de partout au pays certains
spécialistes aussi que nous avons
convoqué de s'ajouter à eux donc
et de dire quels livres canadiens il
faut avoir lu une fois dans sa vie
et vous votre choix oui ces [ __ ] de
nelly arcan quitte une lecture qui m'a
bouleversé il ya quatorze ans que j'ai
relu récemment un texte qui dit
tellement de choses sur le monde dans
lequel on vit
l'hyperconsommation et la prostitution
la pornographie la marchandisation du
corps des femmes
je pense oui je pense je pense que c'est
un discours vraiment vraiment juste
qu'il faut revoir relire merci beaucoup
marie louise alors on peut s'inscrire
sur le site oui on voit l'adresse à
l'écran donc tout le monde peut y aller
de son choix
exact si vous merci à vous merci